colas amir commission je vous remercie
d'être en direct sur arte france
désamorcer la crise entre ankara et
athènes une mission compliquée pour le
chef de l'otan mission très compliquée
depuis plusieurs années la turquie fait
exactement ce qu'elle veut au sein même
de l'otan je vous rappelle que la
turquie occupe une nation souveraine
européenne qui est chypre depuis les
années 70 c'est que ça ne pose aucun
problème à l'otan
et on a vu que ankara aujourd'hui que ce
soir en syrie en libye de la mer
méditerranée justement autour de chypre
en grèce
là ces derniers jours dans le
haut-karabagh auprès de l'armée
azerbaïdjanaise fait ce qu'elle veut et
échappe à tout contrôle de l'otan malgré
des rappels nombreux que ce soit de
stoltenberg ce soit du président marc rô
le de la chancelière merkel
c'est avec une mission très compliquée
parce que l'otan n'arrive plus à
contrôler ses membres
justement qu'est-ce qui pourrait voit la
force et la turquie a essayé
de stopper ce conflit notamment en
méditerranée orientale vous avez parlé
du haut karabagh on sait aussi que
plusieurs mesures de sanction ont été à
plusieurs fois brandie par l'union
européenne et pour l'instant rien n'y
fait parce que ces sanctions
je vous rappelle que notamment sur le
sujet des réfugiés et des migrants ya
quelques mois encore qui était
bouillonnant l'union européenne peut
dire que 2,6 milliards d'euros
la turquie pour qu'elle contrôle le flux
et deux de réfugiés la turquie le fait
ce qu'elle veut elle ouvre les vannes
moderne et l'union européenne est
incapable d'appliquer des sanctions
aujourd'hui au sein d'une organisation
si vous avez un membre elle qui ne
rrespectent plus les règles de
l'organisation
ce monde doit être sanctionné ces
sanctions doivent être appliquées ça
peut être des sanctions financières
la nature qui peut être exclu de
plusieurs réunions de haut commandement
de l'otan
la nasa la nature qui peuvent subir
plusieurs sanctions qui seraient
légitimes parce que du coup la suisse la
turquie et dans ce camp du monde en
train de créer des crises en train de
s'engager dans des guerres qui peuvent
avoir des conséquences néfastes sur la
région c'est cette vidéo nous l'avons
fait en séries nous l'avons burly pire
encore en ce moment dans le
haut-karabagh mais ça peut en avoir
également pour le reste des nations
européennes c'est la turquie est engagée
dans une guerre et que cette guerre là
s'étend à d'autres puissances beaucoup
plus important est ce que les soldats
français seront prêts à lait se battent
pour la nature in pour respecter
l'article numéro 5 de l'otan qui qui
voulait à une défense mutuelle de ses
membres je pense qu'il est important que
le temps applique ces sanctions et que
l'union européenne soit capable de taper
du poing sur la table mais on voit que
l'union européenne ne n'y arrive pas qu
elle se soit au niveau de l'union au
niveau des paiements du mont lassois
turquie faire à la lumière de la gestion
de ces conflits
voilà qui sont qui se déroule
actuellement est ce qu'on peut dire que
la neutralité et la partialité de l'otan
est remise en cause
je pense que l'auteur a jamais été une
organisation neutre l'otan tout est très
simple c'est la légion étrangère de
l'armée américaine l'otan aujourd'hui
répond à des directives américaines le
général on sait de l'otan est toujours
un général américain c'est un projet
américain et les pays membres de l'osce
en subissent ou suivent les directives
américaines et on voit que ça marche pas
aujourd'hui l'otan passe beaucoup plus
de temps à faire des exercices
militaires sur la frontière russe que de
s'occuper des véritables préoccupations
en termes de sécurité des membres de
l'otan aujourd'hui est ce que l'otan à
protéger les européens où ses membres du
terrorisme parce qu'elle a protégé du
corps à un virus est ce qu est la
protégée de différentes menaces qui
s'adresse l'a sûrement de l'otan de
l'otan absolument pas elle s'amuse à
jouer à la guerre sur la frontière russe
parce ce que à la tête de l'otan à
washington
vous avez des vieux généraux américains
qui sont obsédés par la guerre froide
qui ne soit pas au courant que ces cars
est terminé et qu'ils dépensent des
milliards de dollars dans un jeu
politique qui est très dangereux sur les
frontières d'une grande puissance
militaire nucléaire quel hacker la
russie il n'y a pas de l'objectivité de
l'otan c'est pour ça duret d'ailleurs
que donald trump pendant la campagne
électorale a dit que l'otan était
obsolète il est revenu un peu sur ses
paroles depuis suite à la pression du
complexe long terme l'industrie
l'américain mais emmanuel mer contient
quelques mois encore parler de l' état
de mort cérébrale de l'otan je pense
qu'il faut ouvrir les yeux
les enjeux de sécurité deux des membres
de l'otan sont complètement différent
aujourd'hui qu'il n'était en 1949 quand
le temps était a été a été lancé il est
temps maintenant je pense de mettre fin
l'otan tout simplement parce que l'otan
n'est pas objectif l'otan ne répond pas
aux demandes de défense des membres de
ses membres et il est temps d'arrêter
l'auteur de ce peloton et être repensé
la sécurité et la moyenne de dix
répondre pour les pays membres de l'otan
je pense que là dessus révèle même
raison ça fait maintenant six ans que
ian s'acheter solberg est à la tête de
l'otan au delà de la personne
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus une question
de deux dirigeants de chef de l'otan ces
institutions est lui-même qu'il me
faudrait voilà effacer et recommencer si
je veux dire bien sûr de la gauche
norvégienne a quant lui fois qu'on est
heureux mais ce n était ici d'aider
conservateur danois gauche droite c'est
pareil la politique de l'otan va pas
vraiment changé parce que c'est une
politique c'est une politique appliquée
à la stratégie militaire américaine du
coup vous pouvez changer les têtes
la politique va rester la même même si
les caractères sont un peu différents
il faut revoir complètement le temps je
pense que c'est un instrument qui est
désuet je vous rappelle qu'ils avaient
en face d'eux l'auteur ne pas devoir
celui qui les objets aujourd'hui
n'existe plus pourquoi est-ce que le
temps existait encore et surtout à quoi
servent les milliard à 2,2 euros qui
sont dépensés pour les exercices de
l'otan pour faire vivre cette
institution qui ne protège par les
européens je pense que si vous parlez
des problèmes de sécurité des européens
aujourd'hui ils ne vont pas vous parler
d' exercice réalisé mais pour ce mois
que les exercices réalisés par l'otan en
antarctique sur leurs frontières russes
récemment au jour j donc on y protéger
des menaces que ressentent aujourd'hui
dans leur vie de tous les jours
lausanne a récemment rasmussen a dit que
l'otan allait lutter contre le climat le
changement de climat
je pense qu'on n'a jamais vu une force
armée alors à moins que l'otan ait des
armes que nous ignorons lutter contre le
climat
qu'est ce que c'est que c'est lui mais
ils sont complètement déconnectés ils
sont hors sol et je pense qu'ils sont
7es connexion de la réalité point que
avec ses faibles
le budget conséquent qu'il représente
sont des bonnes raisons de vouloir
mettre à plat couple - l'organisation je
pense de l'arrêté de repenser notre
stratégie militaire en tout cas pour la
france peut-être pour d'autres pays
membres de l'union européenne ont pensé
cette stratégie et voir comment se
défendre intelligemment la russie ne
sait plus clairement la lune menace d
pas une menace pour les pays de l'ouest
européen
les européens n'ont pas besoin des
américains ni des turcs pour les
défendre les européens doivent repenser
leur propre stratégie et mettre en face
des moyens pour se défendre et répondre
avant tout aux préoccupations des
citoyens qui sont membres de ces
organisations
merci beaucoup à nicolas mirkovic
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes analyste
politique